and the shooting comes just one day
after education secretary Betsy DeVos
met with a group behind closed doors the
White House survivors and other family
members affected by school shootings the
meeting was supposed to help lay the
groundwork for the administration's new
school safety commission well Jay T
Lewis was part of that meeting he
tragically lost his brother in Sandy
Hook he joins us now live to talk about
where we go from here JT thanks for
joining us tonight thanks for having me
what's your reaction today I mean you've
been through this numerous times hearing
this news since the day you lost your
brother and I know you're frustrated
because you think there are things we
can be doing and we're not doing yeah I
I just feel so bad for all the victims I
know exactly what they're going through
it's it's the rest of your life will be
spent in pain and it's unfortunate
because there are things we can do to
prevent these shootings so we hear from
Education Secretary Betsy DeVos we
simply cannot allow this trend to
continue our work remains urgent our
nation must come together and address
the underlying issues that lead to such
tragic and senseless loss of life very
similar language from the House Minority
Leader Democrat Nancy Pelosi saying no
other community or family must endure
the unthinkable horror of gun violence
our children deserve real leadership a
vote to prevent gun violence now so what
in your estimation is out there you're
part of this conversation with this
effort to find real world solutions what
can be done yeah well first I just want
to take a minute to thank Secretary
teuvos for holding that meeting and for
hearing from members of the community
people who've been affected by these
shootings to get the best possible
information compile it into report
return it to the President and then take
it from there and you know get things
done to stop the shooting it's it's
getting ridiculous at this point but a
few things that I would like to see my
biggest thing is armed guards and
schools
you see schools where there are armed
guards three of the most recent
shootings one in Illinois recently maybe
just Friday where an armed guard
confronts the student apprehension
sometimes a student doesn't even die and
the casualties are kept to one or zero
and that's still too many but it's
better than 17 in parkland 26 in Newtown
a university professor from Northeastern
University his name is James Ellen Fox
he studies these math school shootings
he himself is a proponent of gun control
but he talks about the fact that when
you talk about armed guards or armed
teachers or other safety measures he
worries about the impact he says this
I'm not a big fan of making schools look
like fortresses because they send a
message to kids that the bad guy is
coming for you if we're surrounding you
with security you must have a bull's-eye
on your back and that can actually
instill fear not relieve it as a young
person yourself what do you think of
that well I've talked to my classmates
about this I've talked to a lot of
different people
the idea of armed guards has a lot of
support and I just want to say after
9/11 Airport sided security they did it
because it keeps us safe and it's the
same thing in schools and you get used
to it you know and schools will add the
security will add metal detectors will
add single entry points will add armed
guards and over time we will get used to
it it's for our own safety it's for the
safety of our youth well I know that the
number of armed guards has gone up this
the numbers show us that the studies
show us that and I know it's you're
gonna be a part of this continuing
conversation with this group as they try
to come up with solid answers to this
and there don't seem to be any easy ones
they're gonna take some fighting and
some you know uphill battles to get them
done but we're glad your voice is in the
conversation I can only imagine all of
the emotions you go through today I know
it's your birthday as well so JT thank
you for making time for us and for
continuing to try to be a voice in this
process thank you for having me